This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down,
这是一档由 I-Heart 制作的播客。保证真诚。在 Look Back at it 播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，这对我是个重要的时刻。84 年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每期节目，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，
and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊 80 年代。84 年是个疯狂的年份。真是个疯狂的年份。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说比这更重要。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听 Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？
You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor it? It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
你正在收听的是《用硬核方式去了解》，我是你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着一套或者多套盔甲？它向世界释放出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在 AHA 广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并了解。2023 年，《钻石王老五》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Ellen's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Ranjini. My mind was blown.
埃伦斯女士，你对这份特定的检测做了两次手脚，对吧？我动了一次手脚。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭开了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋，迈克尔·兰吉尼。我的脑洞大开。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困于爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在 IHeart Radio 应用程序、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听 Love Trapped 播客。
Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our 20s. psychology. Thank you everyone for joining us for another episode. This is one that I am incredibly excited about because we have a guest today, a guest all the way from the US, joining us to talk about financial anxiety and all things, money in our 20s. So, hi, Lindsay. Hi, I am so happy to be here. This is really exciting and I'm glad we worked around the time
你好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，这是一档探讨我们在二十多岁时的一些重大生活改变与转变，以及它们对我们二十岁人生意味着什么的播客。感谢大家收听又一期节目。这一期让我感到无比兴奋，因为我们今天迎来了一位嘉宾，一位远道从美国赶来的嘉宾，和我们一起聊聊二十多岁的财务焦虑以及所有关于金钱的话题。嗨，林赛。嗨，我很高兴来到这里。这真的让人兴奋，我也很高兴我们敲定了时区和日期的变更。
zone and day changes as well. Yeah, absolutely. Yeah, that was one thing when you reached out to me. I was like, this is something we're going to need to sort out. It's the fact that you're in the US, I'm in Australia, but you reached out to me and I just thought you had some incredible ideas and you obviously do fantastic work. So do you want to give us a bit of an overview of who you are, what kind of work you do, where you're from? Yeah, sure. So I am based in Michigan in the United States. States. And I'm a financial therapist. So my background is in clinical social work. So I have that psychology training, that sociology training that allows me to be a practicing therapist. I think in Australia you use the term counselor. So I was a practicing therapist for probably eight years or so
对，绝对是的。是的，当你联系我的时候，我就在想，这是我们需要解决的一个问题。你在美国，我在澳大利亚，但你联系了我，我只是觉得你有一些非常了不起的想法，而且你显然做了非常棒的工作。你想给我们大致介绍一下你是谁、做什么样的工作、来自哪里吗？好的，当然。我常驻在美国密歇根州。我是一名金融治疗师。我的背景是临床社会工作。所以我拥有心理学培训、社会学培训的背景，这让我能够成为一名执业治疗师。我想在澳大利亚你们会用“辅导员”这个词。所以我做执业治疗师大概有八年左右的时间，
when I really went all in on financial therapy. And financial therapy is, exactly as it sounds, it's the study of the psychological side of money. So helping people with the emotional side of money, so much less how to make a budget and much more what is making it hard to look at your numbers? What makes you feel uncomfortable when you have to negotiate a pay raise? Is it hard for you to talk to a partner or roommate about your finances? So thinking more about that side of money? Yeah. So that's the short of it, I suppose. That's the short answer. That is an incredible explanation.
然后我真正全力投入到了金融治疗中。金融治疗，顾名思义，就是研究金钱背后的心理学。也就是帮助人们处理金钱的情感层面，它远不只是如何制定预算，而更多的是：是什么让你难以直面你的数字？是什么让你在必须谈判加薪时感到不舒服？你是否很难与伴侣或室友谈论你的财务状况？所以会更多地去思考金钱的那个层面。简而言之，我想就是这样。简短的回答就是这样。这是一个不可思议的解释。
I will say before you reached out to me to come onto the show, I had no idea what financial therapy it was. It's not a massive thing in Australia. It's such a valuable kind of position to have in society. It's such a valuable job to be doing because I think, as you will explain more, especially in our 20s as we begin to navigate our own money, for the first time, it can be really, really stressful. And normally it's a very, I think we think about financial advisors who tell you how to
我想说，在你联系我上节目之前，我根本不知道什么是金融治疗。这在澳大利亚并不是一件大事。在社会中拥有这样一个宝贵的职位，做着这样一份宝贵的工作，因为正如你将进一步解释的那样，特别是在我们二十多岁开始第一次自己理财的时候，这真的会带来非常非常大的压力。通常情况下，我认为我们会想到财务顾问，他们会告诉你如何真正对待你的钱、把钱存放在哪里、如何投资、如何做预算，但它并没有真正考虑到事情的情感层面。带着这个想法，你是怎么进入这种类型的工作的？是什么样的召唤让你开始与客户开展这种类型的工作的呢？嗯，我并没有刻意去寻找成为一名金融治疗师的机会。正如你所提到的，金融治疗是治疗世界中一个相对较新的领域。所以当我拿到学位、硕士学位时，那是 2011 年。我研究生毕业后找到了第一份社会工作。我对此真的感到很兴奋，在一家非营利组织工作。
really treat your money, where to store it, how to invest, how to budget, but it doesn't really account for the emotional side of things. So with that in mind, how did you get into this type of work? What was the kind of calling to begin this type of work with clients? Well, I did not seek out to become a financial therapist. So like you mentioned, financial therapy is a relatively new niche within the world of therapy. So back when I got my degree, my master's degree, it was 2011. And I got my first social work job out of grad school. I was really excited about it, working at a nonprofit.
我拿到了第一份薪水，在我看来，就像是一个成年人了。而我挣的钱比当服务员时还要少。而且，是的，你看不见，因为我们在做播客，但杰玛，我当时下巴都惊掉了。是的。情况是这样的。这并不罕见。进入一个助人领域却挣不到，在我看来能够维持生计的薪水，这并不罕见。但我有太多的内疚和焦虑，在美国，高等教育大学是很昂贵的。我的父母在经济上能够资助我。所以我毕业时没有任何债务。所以，我带着相对的特权，却仍然在为生计苦苦挣扎。
And I got my first paycheck as, in my opinion, like a grown up. And I was earning less than I was as a waitress. And it, yeah, you can't see because we're on a podcast, but Gemma, it's just like jaw just dropped. Yeah. And here's the thing. That's not uncommon. It's not uncommon to go into a helping field and not earn, in my opinion, a living wage. But I had so much guilt and anxiety in the, in the States, higher education university is expensive. I had my parents who were able to financially help me. And so I graduated without any debt. And so here I am with relative financial privilege and I'm still struggling to make ends meet.
我感到十分尴尬，觉得自己浪费了特权或浪费了资源。我简直不敢相信，付房租或买杂货对我来说竟然会变成一场挣扎。这周围充满了太多的羞耻感。所以我做了很多人都会做的事。你知道，我谷歌搜索了如何做预算、如何在低收入情况下维持生计。我从图书馆借了书。当时每个人都对我说同样的话，基本上就是，这是你的错。你真的应该停止出去吃饭。
And I was so embarrassed that I had wasted my privilege or wasted my resources. I couldn't believe that it was going to be a struggle for me to make rent or to get groceries. And there was so much shame around it. And so I did what a lot of people do. You know, I Googled how to make a budget, how to make ends meet on not a high income. I checked out books from the library. And everybody at that point in time was telling me the same thing, basically, like, it's your fault. And you should really stop going out to eat.
而我只是，这对我来说感觉不对。我想，我不是在疯狂购物。我真的只是在努力满足我的基本需求，给车加满油，养活自己，你知道的，付房租。这让我感觉更糟糕了。所以个人财务信息在某种程度上是有帮助的，它帮助我构建了一个预算，并在购物时变得更精明一些。但它并没有像我们被承诺的那样真正扭转局面。在那份工作满一年的时候，我谈了加薪，结果不仅被告知不会加薪，还被告知我应该为自己有工作而感到感激。
And I just, it didn't feel right to me. I was like, I'm not like going on shopping sprees. I'm literally just trying to have my basic needs met, put gas in the car, feed myself. you know, pay my rent. And I just felt even worse. So the personal finance information was somewhat helpful and then it helped me to structure a budget and be a little bit savvier about shopping. But it didn't really move the needle the way that we're kind of promised that it will. And it was a year into that job that I negotiated for a raise and was told not only would I not get a raise, but that I should be grateful that I had a job.
那种感觉我能真切地在胃里翻江倒海。我的心一下子沉了下去。我的胃沉了下去。我在这里感到如此无助。你知道，我做了一切我该做的事。我甚至鼓起勇气去争取加薪，结果却被拒绝了。所以就在那天，我开始找新工作。后来快进一下，我找到了一份薪水更好的工作。
And that I could feel in the pit of my stomach. My heart just sank. My stomach sank. I felt so stuck here. You know, I've done everything I was supposed to. I even, like, mustered up the courage to negotiate a raise and was told no. And so right then I started looking for a new job that day. And so fast forward, I got a better paying job.
当我找到一份薪水更好的工作时，我注意到的是，是的，我的财务状况有所改善，但在我第一份工作时发生的情况是，我不仅对金钱感到压力，而且正如你可以想象的那样，研究你所做的事并讨论金钱的心理学，或者抱歉，讨论你二十多岁的心理学，当我们在生活的某些领域感到压力时，它会影响我们生活的其他领域。所以我之前控制得很好的抑郁和焦虑复发了，我患上了失眠，我一直感冒和流感，因为你可以想象，如果你不睡觉，你的免疫系统就会崩溃。这简直是一个恶性、恶性的循环。
and what I noticed when I got a better paying job was that, yes, my finances improved, but what had happened when I was at my first job was not only was I stressed out about money, but as you can imagine studying what you do and talking about the psychology of money, or I'm sorry, the psychology of your 20s, is that when we feel stressed in certain areas of our life, it impacts other areas of our life. So my previously well-managed depression and anxiety had flared up, I developed insomnia and I was getting colds and flus all the time because as you can imagine if you're not sleeping, your immune systems run down. It's just this vicious, vicious cycle.
所以快进，我找到了这份薪水更好的工作。我对维持生计感觉好多了。我注意到我的抑郁和焦虑实际上开始消退了。我开始能在晚上入睡了。突然间，我的免疫系统也没有那么糟糕了。杰玛，那一刻我突然意识到：你知道的，我们可以整天告诉人们，少喝拿铁，少吃牛油果吐司，但我们真正需要讨论的是低收入带来的情感后果。而且，你知道，对于少数人来说，当然，这可能在某种程度上是管理不善，但我真的认为其中很大一部分原因是，我们中的很多人并没有为我们所做的工作得到充分的报酬。我们最终进入了那些报酬不高的助人和疗愈行业，而这在这些行业是很普遍的。所以，然后，
So fast forward, I get this better paying job. I'm feeling better about making my ends meet. And I noticed that my depression and anxiety actually starts to dial down. I start to be able to sleep at night. Suddenly my immune system isn't so terrible. And it was just this moment, Jama, of being like, You know, we can tell people all day, cut, cut the lattes, cut the avocado toast, but we really need to be talking about the emotional consequences of under-earning. And, you know, for a handful of people, sure, it might be mis-management in some way, but I really think a big part of it is that a lot of us aren't paid adequately for the work that we do. And we, we end up in fields helping healing professions where it's commonplace to not earn that much. So, then,
让我想想。然后我开始研究金融社会工作和金融治疗。最终，我为自己开辟了一个细分市场，真正只服务于那些在金钱的情感层面挣扎的客户。这非常充实，也非常具有认可感。但这不是我刚上大学时设想要做的事，也没有做过什么宏伟的计划。是的。嗯，这真的很不可思议。而且我想，很多人可能会对你谈到的那种经历感同身受，在你找到第一份像样的大女孩工作之后，你开始赚钱了，你几乎期望能感到安全，但那种情况并没有真正发生。尤其是现在，正如你所知，生活成本
Let's see. Then I started studying financial social work and financial therapy. And eventually, I carved out a niche for myself and went into really only serving clients who are struggling with the emotional side of money. And it has been incredibly fulfilling, incredibly validating. But no, it is never what I set out to do or had great plans of doing when I was in university. Yeah. Well, that is actually incredible. And I'm, I, think a lot of people could probably relate to that experience you were talking about after you get your first like big girl job, you're making money and you almost expect to feel secure, but that just doesn't really happen. And especially now as, you know, the cost of living
变得越来越高。从财务上讲，我们看到通货膨胀正在上升。然而，就像你说的，许多毕业生岗位，也就是刚毕业就找到的工作，薪水绝对一文不值或者非常少，特别是如果你在从事护理相关角色。如果你是一名护士、一名辅导员、一名职业治疗师、一名初级心理学家，所有这些都会在你心中产生大量的担忧。所以就你接待的客户而言，他们中的大多数人是比较年轻还是年长？我对你接待的人群的年龄跨度真的很感兴趣。是的，很好，很好的问题。
becomes more expensive. Financially, we're seeing, you know, inflation is on the rise. And yet still, like you said, a lot of, I would say graduate jobs, the jobs that you get straight out of, you need pay absolutely nothing or very little, and especially if you're working in, you know, caring roles. If you're a nurse, if you're a counselor, if you're an occupational therapist, an entry-level psych, that is all stuff that is going to create a lot of worry within you. So in terms of the clients that you see, the majority of them kind of younger or older in their lives, I would really be interested in the spectrum of the people that you see. Yeah, great, great question.
我是千禧一代。所以我可以说我的大部分客户也是千禧一代，但我确实有一些年纪稍大的和年纪稍小的。所以我想说我的大多数客户年龄在 28 到 40 岁之间，但也有一定的范围。你知道，有些稍微年长一点，有些稍微年轻一点。但他们大多数人来找我时，已经经历过一两次职业生涯，或者说经历过职业转型。他们终于开始赚钱了，但仍然存在这种恐惧。
So I'm a millennial. So I would say the bulk of my clients are also millennials, but I do have a handful that are older and a handful that are younger. So I would say most of my clients are like 28 to 40, but they range. You know, some are a bit older, some are a bit younger. But most of them are coming to me. They've had a couple of careers, career changes rather under their belt. They're starting to finally earn money, but there's still this fear.
童年或是大学毕业后挣得不多的日子留下的焦虑依然存在。这很大程度上是帮助他们适应他们现在所处的位置与过去的对比。所以我在实践中处理很多财务焦虑和金钱羞耻感。这就触及了我今天真正想向你请教的问题，也就是首要的财务焦虑。然后，作为二十多岁的个体，我们该如何应对艰难的对话，以及当你谈论金钱时如何处理你的人际关系？
There's still this anxiety that's left over from their childhood or from the post-uny days where they weren't earning that much. And it's a lot of helping them to navigate where they are now versus where they were before. So I deal with a lot of financial anxiety and a lot of money shame in my practice. So this kind of gets to what I really want to pick your brain about today, which is financial anxiety first and foremost. But then how do we as individuals in our 20s, a lot of my audiences, obviously, people in the 20s. How do you navigate difficult conversations and also your relationships when you're
我觉得，是的，这是一个相当大的问题。而我们大约只有一个小时来回答它。我想我们还是从财务焦虑开始吧。你能给我们做个概述吗？它感觉是怎样的？它看起来是怎样的？当然。财务焦虑是指当你接触或思考金钱时，感到紧张、担忧或坐立不安。这在身体上的表现几乎与传统焦虑的表现完全一样。它的表现可以是胃里打结、手心出汗、口干舌燥、咬紧牙关、坐立难安，对吧？它可以通过这些方式表现出来。
talking about money? I think, yeah, it's a pretty big question. And we have like an hour to answer it. But I guess we'll start with financial anxiety. Can you give us the laydown? What does it feel like? What does it look like? Of course. Financial anxiety is when you feel nervous, worried or on edge, when you are engaging with or thinking about your money. And that can show up almost identical in your body the way that traditional anxiety shows up. It can show up by knots in your stomach, your palm sweating, dry mouth, clenching of your teeth, feeling jittery, right? It can show up in those ways.
它通常表现为赛跑般飞转的担忧思绪。其行为表现是，当一个有财务焦虑的人查看他们的工资单、退休账户或可用资金时（你知道，生活中的某个地方），他们会感受到焦虑的症状。当我们感到焦虑症状时，我们会尽一切努力不去感受它们，对吧？没有人喜欢那种胃里翻江倒海、坐立不安以及伴随焦虑而来的疯狂感觉。所以有两种非常快的方法来关闭这种不适感。一种是通过完美主义，另一种是通过拖延。带有财务焦虑的完美主义表现为：
It often shows up in racing, worried thoughts. And the way that the behavior show up is that when a person who has financial anxiety looks at their paycheck or their retirement account or how much money is available, you know, somewhere in their life. They feel those symptoms of anxiety. And when we feel symptoms of anxiety, we do everything in our power to not feel them, right? Nobody likes that like churning in your stomach and the jitteriness and the craziness that comes along with anxiety. So there are two really quick ways to shut down this discomfort. One is through perfect. perfectionism and one is through procrastination. So perfectionism with financial anxiety looks like saying,
“我要研究我能找到的每一家银行，把我的钱存在最好的一家。”或者“我要查看墨尔本的每一份早午餐菜单，挑选出最便宜的那家选项，”对吧？这类过度研究，试图用正确的方式来驯服他们的财务焦虑。另一方面，则是拖延。如果我不想感受到那种财务焦虑，我就干脆不去处理我的金钱问题。我不看银行账户。我不考虑退休。我甚至懒得去告诉老板他们发薪水迟到了。比如，我根本没有心力去看它，因为它带来了太多的焦虑。关于财务焦虑，有趣的一点是，这是一个神话：如果你有更多的钱或赚更多的钱，你就不会再经历财务焦虑了。我们当中有很多人即使在不断赚取更多、即使在不断储蓄更多时，依然会经历它，因为它太情绪化了，与逻辑的联系较少。
I'm going to research every single bank that I can find and put my money in the best one. Or I'm going to look at every single brunch menu in Melbourne and choose the one that has the cheapest option, right? So these kinds of like over researching, trying to do it the right way in order to tame their financials. financial anxiety. And on the other hand, you have procrastination. If I don't want to feel that financial anxiety, I just won't deal with my money. I won't look at my bank account. I won't think about retirement. I won't even worry about telling my boss that they're a paycheck late. Like, I just don't even have the capacity to look at it because it brings up so much anxiety. And something interesting about financial anxiety is that it's a myth that if you have more
这真的非常有趣，比如那种拖延和完美主义。我认为在某一个特定方面它非常有趣，那就是这两件事，也就是处理金钱的那些方式，可以说是相当被社会所接受的。是的，是的，绝对的。你知道，我想我有时倾向于拖延，
money or earn more money, you'll stop experiencing financial anxiety. So many of us experience it even as we continue to earn more, even as we continue to save more, because it's so emotional and it's less tied to logic. That is incredibly interesting, like that that procrastination and that perfectionism. And I think it's very interesting in one way in particular is that both of those things, those ways of dealing with money are quite socially accepted, I would say. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. You know, I think I sometimes lead towards procrastination,
现在我想，哦，这只是因为我为自己的收入感到焦虑，还是我只是懒惰？但同时那种完美主义，（真正清醒地意识到进账和出账是多少）被人们视为成熟的标志、明智的标志以及良好习惯的标志。所以我有一个可能更细致的问题要问你，那就是这两种行为是从哪里来的呢？会不会有不同的人更倾向于其中一种而不是另一种？
and now I'm thinking like, oh, this is just because I'm anxious about my income, or am I just lazy? But also that perfectionism, you know, being really conscious about what's coming in and what's going out is something that people see as a sign of maturity and as a sign of being wise and of good practice. So I have kind of maybe a more nuanced question for you, which is where do those two behaviors come from? Are there different people who might be leaning towards one over the other?
或者说，最初导致财务焦虑的决定因素有哪些？是的，好问题。所以它们可能是同一个人，也就是说你可能通过完美主义的方式在拖延，对吧？你可能会因为想把与金钱相关的事情做得恰到好处而推迟去做。如果你不能把它做得恰到好处，你干脆就不做了。但这又回到了这个观点：我们没有被教导如何应对焦虑，但我们绝对没有被教导如何理财。所以当你把这两者结合起来时，我们所拥有的资源实在是太少了。
Or what are some of the determinants of financial anxiety to begin with? Yeah, good question. So they can be the same person in that you could be procrastinating by way of perfectionism, right? You could be putting off doing something related to your money because you want to do it just right. And if you can't do it just right, you don't do it at all. But it again goes back to this idea of we're not taught how to deal with anxiety, but we're certainly not taught how to deal with finances. So when you combine those two, there are, there's just so few resources for us. You know, I'm so thankful for the explosion and information of psychoeducation on,
你知道，我非常感谢 TikTok、Instagram 播客上心理教育信息的爆发式增长，我认为它给了我们更多的正当理由去说：哦，有这种感觉的人不只有我一个。但当谈到财务焦虑时，我们真的不会去谈论它。所以它可以源于很多不同的事情，但实际上，正是飞转思绪和身体不适的物理感觉，让我们用完美主义或拖延来进行补偿。而且正如你之前所说，研究最好的银行账户并不一定不受欢迎。这有什么不好呢？但它不好的地方在于，有时它会优先于真正去弄清楚他们希望自己与金钱的关系是什么样子的。登录银行账户却没有那种焦虑的浪潮，会是怎样的体验？
TikTok, Instagram podcasts, I think it gives us so much more validity to say, oh, I'm not alone in feeling this way. But when it comes to financial anxiety, we just don't really talk about it. So it can come from a bunch of different things, but really it is the physical sensation of racing thoughts and feeling uncomfortable is what makes us compensate with perfectionism or procrastination. And to your point earlier, these things are not necessarily frowned upon to research the best bank account. What's bad about that? But what's bad about it is that it can sometimes take precedence of actually figuring out what they want their relationship with money to look like. What would it be like to log into your bank account and not feel that wave of anxiety?
去吃早午餐却不用觉得自己必须提前一个星期把所有东西都研究透，会是怎样的体验？所以真正去思考：试图避免财务焦虑所花费的精力，与仅仅说“我可以容忍一点点不适感，我可以学会度过这个难关，我可以了解金钱，也能了解我与金钱的关系，这样如果我经历财务焦虑，希望随着时间的推移，它的强度会减弱，或者频率会降低”相比，哪个更多？是的，这真的是一个很好的解释。当我刚开始谈论或与你交谈时，思考你所做的工作，这真的引起了我的极大兴趣。也许这更偏向心理学，更偏向弗洛伊德学派。但你是否能指出，也许是小时候或更年轻时发生的事情，最终可能会演变成财务焦虑？你是否倾向于在你的客户中看到，也许那些在成长过程中没有那么多东西的人真的在为此挣扎，或者那些拥有不稳定的收入来源，或者他们的父母有不稳定的工作或某种财务途径的人？这是否是你在客户身上倾向于看到的现象？我当然看到了。
What would it be like to go to brunch and not have to feel like you had to research everything? you know, for a week in advance before you went there. So really thinking about the amount of effort that it takes to try and avoid financial anxiety versus just saying, I can tolerate a little bit of discomfort. I can learn to move through this. I can learn about money and also my relationship about money so that if I experience financial anxiety, hopefully it's either less intense or less frequent over time. Yeah, that's really, I think, a great explanation. This is something when I first started talking or talking to you, thinking about the work that you do that really interests me. And perhaps it is a bit more psychology, a bit Freudian. But can you kind of point to perhaps things
所以我们无法摆脱我们的童年。就像我们从童年中了解到许多关于我们看待世界的方式一样，我们在童年时就开始了解金钱。研究发现，到八岁时，我们大多数人或多或少已经对金钱是什么、不是什么，或者我们被允许用它做什么、不被允许做什么做出了决定。
that have happened as a child or when you're younger that might manifest in financial anxiety? Do you tend to see that with your clients that perhaps people who didn't have as much growing up really struggle with this or those who had kind of inconsistent income streams or their parents had inconsistent jobs or kind of financial avenues. Is that something you tend to see with your clients? Of course I do. So we cannot escape our childhoods. And just like we learn many things about the way in which we view the world from our childhood, we learn about money as children. And research has found that most of us have more or less made a decision about what money is or isn't or what we're allowed to do or not do with it by the time we're eight years old.
哦，天哪。是的。所以这真的很有趣，因为许多成年人不想和他们的孩子谈论金钱。我可以想象许多父母对他们五岁、六岁、七岁的孩子说：“凯文，嘿，妈妈，你挣多少钱？”迎来的回应却是：“我们不谈这个。这很粗鲁。这很不礼貌。”所以，当然，我们的童年发挥了作用。
Oh, God. Yeah. So it's really interesting because many adults, they don't want to talk to their kids about money. I can imagine many parents saying to their child, who's five, six, six, seven, Kevin, hey, mom, how much money do you earn being met with a response of like, we don't talk about it. It's rude. That's impolite. So, of course, our childhood comes into play.
我们对金钱的认知不仅来自我们的照顾者，还来自我们的朋友、我们上学的地方、我们长大的社区、我们所拥有的精神或宗教实践。还有影响我们的不同法律和政策。所以不仅是我们长大的房子，还有那栋房子坐落在哪里，以及房子之外的所有层面。而这，当然会影响成年人的财务焦虑。如果你想象内心的那个小孩在某种程度上在驱动着财务决策，这就完全说得通了，为什么那么多成年人会如此挣扎，或者做出一些让他们自己都觉得“我不知道为什么我一直在这样处理我的钱”的事情，对吧？
And we learn about money, not just from our caregivers, but also from our friends, from where we attend school, from what neighborhood we grow up in, from what spiritual or religious practices we have. And then also the different laws and policies that impact us. So it's not just the house we grew up in, but also where was that house located and what are all the layers outside of that house as well? And that, of course, can impact an adult's financial anxiety. If you imagine that the inner child is kind of driving financial decisions, it makes perfect sense why so many adults struggle so much or do things where they're like, I don't know why I keep doing this with my money, right? Yeah, that is very, very interesting. love that you said, you know, my inner child is the one who is making financial decisions. Because I think that really sticks with me and some of my own financial decisions.
是的，这非常非常有趣。我喜欢你说的“我内心的那个小孩在做财务决策”。因为我觉得这句话真的深深触动了我，以及我自己的某些财务决策。我会想，哦，你知道，因为我小时候可能觉得这些东西对我来说是不可或缺的，或者不被允许进行这些购买，所以现在我要买这个。我想，另一个我非常想和你探讨的大问题是：接下来该去哪里？你知道，你有了这样的经历，你围绕自己对金钱的情感反应的处理方式，创造了这样一种行为模式。如果我现在是一名客户，如果我的听众是一名客户，你能给我们概述一下你会给他们什么建议吗？
I'm like, oh, you know, because I perhaps didn't feel this was available to me as a child or wasn't allowed to make these purchases, like now I'm going to buy this. And I think, I guess like another really big thing I want to talk to you about is where do you go from there? You know, you've had this experience, you've, you know, created this pattern of behaviors around how you deal with your emotional reactions to money. And if I was a client right now, if my audience was a client, can you give us an overview of what advice you would give them? Yeah, I would love to.
是的，我很乐意。所以让我们想象一下，你二十多岁，成长在一个手头拮据的家庭，对吧？你无意中听到你的父母或照顾者说：“哦，我们买不起那个，”或者“哦，我们需要给公用事业公司打电话，我担心我们这个月付不起账单了，”或者被告知“不行，你不能去那次实途考察，或者我们买不起、我们去不起度假。”所以这些都是你在家里听到的很多信息。在成长过程中，你对金钱感到相当焦虑和紧张。快进到二十出头，你从父母那里内化到的信息是：努力工作非常重要，
So let's imagine you're in your 20s and you grew up in a household where money was tight, right? You overheard your parents or your caregivers saying like, oh, we can't afford that or oh, we need to call the utility company. I'm worried we're not going to be able to make bills this month or being told, nope, you can't go on that field trip or we're not, we don't, we can't afford to go on holiday. So those are a lot of the messages you heard in your household. And growing up, you felt quite anxious and nervous about money. And fast forward to being in your early 20s, the message you internalized from your parents was it's important to work really hard. so that you don't have to struggle. So then that young adult may end up coping with their financial
这样你就不用挣扎了。因此，那个年轻人最终可能会通过陷入工作狂来应对他们的财务焦虑——那种他们会没有安全感的恐惧。但却做着一份公司的工作，然后还有一份副业，拒绝和朋友出去玩，这样他们就可以省钱。所以这可能是他们处理问题的方式，他们的财务焦虑表现为完美主义。所以我给那种年轻人的建议是：你不再能够满足自己需求的说法到底有多真实？这个月付账单会很困难的说法到底有多真实？并且要非常清楚地认识到你现在在哪里，与你小时候相比又在哪里。带着很多的同情心、很多的善意，说一些这样的话：
anxiety that fear that they won't have enough by throwing themselves into workaholism, let's say. But working a corporate job and then having a side hustle and saying no to hanging out with friends so that they can save money. And so that might be how they deal with that, that their financial anxiety shows up as perfectionism. So what advice I would give to that type of young adult is how true is it that you are no longer able to meet your needs? How true is it that it's going to be difficult to pay the bills this month? And to get really clear on where you are now versus where you were as a child. And with a lot of compassion, a lot of kindness saying something like, you know, oh, it makes sense that it's so important for me to work hard and save a lot of money.
“哦，我努力工作并存很多钱，这对我来说如此重要，这是合情合理的。而我已经不再是那个六七岁的孩子了。我现在有能力为雨天存钱了，而且我有足够的余裕每隔一个周末和朋友们聚在一起喝一杯叙叙旧。”这就是我们处理它的方式：逻辑，然后弥合这一差距，并追溯到他们可能最终陷入完美主义和过度工作作为应对童年方式的情感原因。是的。而且这些确实是应对机制，我想，当我们把注意力从情感体验中转移开时，这就像，我认为这是一个非常教科书式的应对机制。
And I'm no longer that six or seven year old child. I now have the capacity to have money set aside for a rainy day. And I have more than enough to be able to join my friends every other weekend to catch up over drinks. So that would be the way that we would deal with it is logic. and then also bridging that gap and tying back into that emotional reason why they might have ended up in perfectionism and overworking as a way to deal with their childhood. Yeah. And those are such coping mechanisms, I think, you know, when we distract ourselves from our emotional experiences, it's like, I think it's a very textbook coping mechanism.
我非常喜欢你对这一点的解释，即真正有意识地思考这些行为可能来自哪里。从澳大利亚的角度来看，对于身在澳大利亚的听众来说，除非你和别人非常非常亲密，否则讨论金钱是一个真正的禁忌话题。围绕金钱的讨论并不常见。我认为，在澳大利亚，那些有能力从财务角度享受生活、将钱投资于他们想要的东西以及做长期财务决策的人，与没有这种机会的人之间，也存在着巨大的财务鸿沟。所以从系统层面或者社会层面来思考，
And I love that the way that you've explained that about really consciously thinking about where that would have come from. I also think from an Australian perspective for our listeners who are in Australia, it is a real taboo thing to discuss money unless you are very, very close with other people. Discussions around money are not something that is frequently had. There's also, I think, a massive financial gap in Australia between those who can afford to enjoy their lives from a financial standpoint and invest money in things that they want and long-term financial decisions and those who do not have that opportunity. So thinking about a system-wide level
你认为社会需要改变什么，才能让更少的人在进入二十多岁或成年晚期时经历这种围绕财务的深层情感反应？我喜欢这个问题。当 2007、2008 年大衰退发生时，我刚好读完大学并直接毕业进入那个时期。所以我对它记忆犹新。但世界卫生组织当时做了一项关于人们心理健康的研究，并叠加了他们的财务状况。那项研究发现，在拥有更强社会安全网、金融安全网的国家，人们的心理健康受到的影响较小。
or about a societal level, what do you think needs to change in society so that we see less people coming into their 20s or late adulthood experiencing this really deep emotional reaction around their finances? I love this question. When the first, when the Great Recession happened back in 2007, eight, I was just finishing up university and graduating right into that. So I remember it very well. But the World Health Organization at that point in time did a study of people's mental health and layered on how they were doing financially. And what that research found was that in countries where there were stronger social safety nets, financial safety nets, people's mental health was less impacted.
所以当我思考我们如何才能保护年轻人免于经历不必要的财务焦虑时，我总是会想到这些数据，对吧？我们可以帮助改善家庭动态，但你或我都无力改变系统和法律，除非倡导改变系统和法律。所以我认为在基准线上，我非常喜欢全球范围内正在发生的工会化和组织化浪潮，对更高工资、带薪休假的诉求。在美国，我们甚至没有产假和陪产假。这太，是的，我们，这让我感到震惊。是的，我们没有。在某些工作中，你可以获得 12 周的工作岗位保护，但
So I think of that data all the time when I'm thinking about how can we protect our young people from having to experience unnecessary financial anxiety, right? We can help with the family dynamics, but you or I don't have the capacity to change the systems and laws outside of advocating for changes in systems and laws. So I think at baseline, I'm loving all of the worker unionization and organization that is happening globally, the demand for higher wages, for paid time off. In the U.S., we don't even have maternity and paternity leave. Like that is, yeah, we, that's shocking to me. Yeah, we don't have it. You can, in some jobs, you can have 12 weeks of your job protected, but
是没有薪水的。所以拥有诸如产假、陪产假之类的东西，拥有像育儿支持这样的东西——在美国，几乎没有托育服务，直到孩子上学上幼儿园。其他一切都是要付费的。但无论你是在美国、澳大利亚，还是在欧洲收听这个节目，拥有一个强大的社会安全网，能够接住人们，让他们能够满足基本需求：食物、住所、衣物、交通，这会产生巨大的差异。我们知道的是，当这些需求得到满足时，人们会报告说他们的情绪有所改善。所以我认为，对于澳大利亚或其他地方的年轻人来说，不断倡导建立这些类型的政策，不仅为你自己和你的朋友，而且为了全球健康和你们国家的健康，我们知道当这些需求得到满足时，在心理上会产生巨大的差异。
unpaid. So having things like maternity, paternity leave, having things like child care in the U.S. there's almost no child care until a child goes to school and in kindergarten. Everything else is paid. But whether you're U.S.-based, Australia-based, you're listening to this in Europe, having a strong social safety net that can capture people so that they can have their basics needs met, food, shelter, clothing, transportation, that makes a huge difference. And what we know is that when those needs are met, people report that their mood improves. So I think for young people in Australia or elsewhere to continually advocate to have those types of policies in place, not just for yourself and for your friends, but for the global health and for your country's health, we know that it makes
是的，精彩绝伦的回答。我赞同其中的每一个部分。我认为从我在澳大利亚的自身经验来看，我们看到人们在极力推动扩大社会安全网。我认为我们已经拥有了一个相当了不起的体系。我们确实有带薪产假。我们有一个相当了不起的社会保障体系，叫做 Centrelink。
a huge difference mentally when those needs are met. Yeah, and fabulous, fabulous answer. And I agree with every single part of it. I think speaking from my own experience in Australia, we're seeing a huge push towards expanding social safety nets. I think we already have a pretty amazing system. We do get paid maternity leave. We have a pretty amazing social security system called Centrelink.
但围绕这一事实也存在着巨大的讨论，即人们每天收到的补助有时不到 30 或 40 美元。我想身为金融治疗师的你可以非常清楚地看到这一点。而且我想大多数人总体而言，从如此不稳定的状态出发去建立一个坚实的情感和心理基础，可能并不是一个好地方。没错。完全正确。
But there have been huge discussions around the fact that it is sometimes less than $30, $40 a day that people are receiving. And I think that yourself as a financial therapist can very clearly see that. And I think most people in general, that's probably not a great place to build a solid, emotional and psychological foundation from a place of such instability. Right. Exactly. Exactly.
如果我们继续把改善财务健康的责任推给个人，我们就会让每个人变得更好变得更加困难，对吧？这必须是双管齐下的。必须有到位的系统来帮助我们取得成功，而且我们必须获得教育渠道，以便我们能够对自己的财务做出明智的决定。是的，我完全同意。所以到目前为止我们已经讨论了很多事情。我们讨论了我们的内联结，也就是内心的孩子。我们讨论了系统级的方法。关于你与财务相关的个人心理状态。但我现在想转向讨论我们如何在人际关系中管理金钱？我觉得这是我们深入探讨的下一个分析单元。
And if we continue to put it on individuals to improve their financial health, we can to make it harder for everybody to get better, right? It has to be a both-end. It has to be the systems are in place to help us succeed, and we have to have access to education so that we can make our own wise decisions about our finances. Yeah, I absolutely agree. So we've talked about a lot of things so far. We've talked about our inner child. We've talked about system-wide approaches. about your individual kind of mental state in relation to your finances. But I kind of want to move on now to talking about how do we manage money in our relationships? I feel like it's the next unit of analysis for us to kind of dive into.
是的。进入二十多岁或成年期自然会伴随着一些重大的财务变化。当人们进入长期关系、与朋友甚至与家人相处时，你对他们如何处理财务有什么看法？所以我想当你处于二十多岁并经历向职业生涯过渡的过程中时，通常会从没有多少钱转变为至少赚到更好的钱。随之而来的是更多与朋友一起做事情的机会。但正如我们所知，同一个同龄人圈子里的人并不都赚取相同的收入。
Yeah. There are obviously some big financial changes that come with entering our 20s or adulthood. What do you kind of see when it comes to people navigating their finances when, you know, they enter long-term relationships or with friends or even with family. So I think as you are in your 20s and you're going through that transition into, you know, your career, there's often a shift from not making much money into making at least better money. And with that comes more opportunities to do things with your friends. But as we know, people in the same peer group don't all make the same income.
他们并不都住在同一个公寓大楼里，对吧？我们的收入不同，开销也不同。所以让我们先聊聊朋友，然后是伴侣关系，最后是恋爱关系。当谈到朋友时，许多人最终选择对朋友进行“幽灵化”（不告而别），而不是说：“嘿，我承担不起那个费用。”对吧。很多人会想：“我不愿告诉朋友我不能去品酒，或者我不能加入他们那个短途假期。”
They don't all live in the same apartment complex, right? we have different income and we have different expenses. So let's talk about maybe friends and then relationships and then romantic relationships. So when it comes to friends, so many people fall into ghosting their friends rather than saying, hey, I can't afford that. Right. So many people are like, you know, I don't want to tell my friends that I can't go wine taser or I can't join them for that, you know, mini holiday.
相反，我会说“好啊，听起来不错”，然后同一天爽约或取消行程。随着时间的推移，如果我们不告诉朋友我们为什么不加入他们，那么他们停止发出邀请就完全说得通了，而这本可以通过与他们进行一次相对坦诚的对话来避免（虽然你不需要分享一切）。在这个场景中，假设你是一个收入比你的朋友圈低，或者有不同财务优先级的人。他们喜欢花钱的聚会，而你觉得，嗯，我一个月可以做一次、两次，但这并不是我的首选，或者我没法每周都去。所以与其选择
instead I'll just kind of say, sure, sounds great and then not show or cancel on the same day. And over time, what happens if we don't tell our friends why we're not joining them, it makes perfect sense that they would stop extending that invitation versus having a relatively candid, but you don't have to share everything conversation with them. So in this scenario, let's say you're a person who's earning less than your friend group or maybe has different financial priorities than your friend group. And they love hangouts that involve spending money and at a point where you're like, I mean, I could do that once a month, twice a month, but it's not a priority for me or I'm not able to do it every week. So rather than ghosting,
短期内轻松但长期来看更困难的“幽灵化”做法，我建议人们在那个朋友圈里找到和你最亲近的那个人，和他们聊聊，然后说：“嘿，这有点让人不舒服，”对吧？说出这种情绪，说出这种感觉，“但我现在的财务状况是，我很想做你们正在做的事情，但我目前做不到。我们能不能做一些低成本或零成本的活动呢？”然后给他们一些脑海中想到的点子。我们可以去远足，我们可以在我家搞个potluck（各带一道菜的聚餐），我们可以租碟在 Netflix 上看电影，给他们提供一些你们可以一起做的事情的点子。而我发现，大多数时候，另一端的人，也就是接收到这个信息的人，通常
which is easy in the short term, but harder in the long term, I advise people to kind of of that friend group, find the one that you're the closest to have a chat with them and just say, hey, this is a little bit uncomfortable, right? Name the emotion, name the feeling, but I'm at a place financially where I'd love to do the things that y'all are doing, but I'm not able to. Would it be possible to do some low or no-cost activities and then give them ideas of things that come to mind? We could go on a hike, we could do a potluck at my house, we could rent, watch a movie on Netflix, like give them some ideas of things that you could do. And what I think, find most of the time is that the person on the other end, the person receiving it is usually,
A，很高兴知道他们没有无缘无故地被“幽灵化”。但 B，他们也为有了另一种活动选择而感到松了一口气。我认为在美国和澳大利亚，把去酒吧作为首选活动非常普遍。但我们还可以做很多其他事情。我们经常忘记，除了去酒吧或出去吃饭之外，还有其他选择，所以提醒你的朋友这一点。所以我对友谊的建议是：进行透明的对话。你不必告诉他们你赚多少钱或你的房租是多少。你只需说：“听你们说，我很想和你一起玩，但你们选择的活动实在太贵了，或者，你知道的，我的预算更适合……”
A, thankful to know that they weren't being ghosted on for no reason. But B, they're also so relieved to have another option of things to do. I think in the States and Australia, it's very common for like the go-to activity to be going out to a pub. But there are so many other things that we can do. And we often forget that there are options aside from going to the bar or going out to eat and so reminding your friends of that. So that's what I would say for friendships is, is have a transparent conversation. You don't have to tell them how much money you're earning or how much your rent is. You can just say, look, I'd love to hang out with you, but y'all choose really expensive activities or, you know, my budget better accommodates
A，很感激得知他们并不是无缘无故地被放鸽子。但B，他们也为有另一种活动选择而感到松了一口气。我认为在美国和澳大利亚，首选活动通常是去酒吧，这非常普遍。但我们可以做的事情还有很多。我们经常忘记除了去酒吧或出去吃饭之外还有其他选择，所以要提醒你的朋友这一点。这就是我对友谊的建议，那就是进行一次坦诚的对话。你不必告诉他们你赚多少钱或房租是多少。你只需说，听着，我很想和你一起玩，但你们选择的活动太贵了，或者，你知道的，我的预算更适合
activities like this. That is great language to use. Like my budget better accommodates activities like this provide the example. She's literally scripting your lives. Yeah, just copy and paste. Put it into a text message. If phone calls freak you out, put it into a text. Then you can spend some time kind of revisiting it, sitting on it, and then just end it. You'll be pleasantly surprised. I think so many people are much more understanding than we imagine they will be. Yeah.
像这样的活动。这是很好的用语。比如，我的预算更好地支持像这样的活动，给出这个例子。她简直是在为你们的生活写剧本。是的，直接复制粘贴。把它发到短信里。如果打电话让你感到恐慌，那就发短信。然后你可以花点时间重新审视它，琢磨一下，然后就结束。你会惊喜的。我觉得很多人比我们想象的要包容得多。是的。
And I think it's also kind of a great litmus test for your quality of your friendships. You know, if your friendships. Exactly. Yeah. If they're not willing to accommodate your individual financial situation or your financial priorities, perhaps it's good to see if they are willing to accommodate you as an entire individual and all that comes with. I think another thing, and perhaps it's very similar, but I would really like to ask you for your advice or what you think about this is the tendency to feel pressure
而且我认为这也是检验你友谊质量的一个很好的试金石。你知道，如果你们的友谊。没错。是的。如果他们不愿意迁就你的个人财务状况或你的财务优先事项，或许可以看看他们是否愿意包容作为一个完整独立的你以及随之而来的一切。我认为还有一点，可能非常相似，但我真的很想向你征求建议，或者你想听听你对此的看法，那就是感到压力的倾向
to spend more money than you perhaps have or want to spend. And what some of the consequences that might have for your well-being, but also for your financial state and And what do we do around that kind of conundrum? This is a good question. So this is a phenomenon called lifestyle inflation. And what that means is when you earn more money, you spend more money. So as we move from entry-level careers to maybe mid-level careers, so think from like your early 20s to your mid or late 20s,
花比你可能拥有或想要花得更多的钱。这可能会对你的幸福感产生什么后果，同时对你的财务状况也会有什么影响？我们该如何应对这种困惑呢？这是个好问题。这是一个被称为生活方式膨胀的现象。这意味着当你赚了更多钱时，你也会花更多的钱。因此，当我们从刚入职场的职业生涯过渡到或许是中级职业生涯时，比如从20岁出头到20岁中期或晚期，
so hopefully you're moving up in pay and you're able to earn more money, which we love. And oftentimes what happens is that then you start. spending the way that other people in those positions do, right? So you move out of your one-bedroom flat and you move into a house or you move from kind of the rural area into the city. And then you're surrounded by people who have slightly nicer cars and slightly nicer clothes and their nails are done and their hair is done all the time and they go and get monthly facials and massages. And before you know it, you find yourself doing those same types of things. With my clients, I find it's less about, my clients aren't the ones typically who are like very brand name heavy, but we're all
所以希望你的薪水在上涨，能够赚到更多的钱，我们很乐意看到这一点。通常发生的情况是，然后你开始像处于那些职位其他人一样花钱，对吧？所以你搬出一居室公寓，搬进一栋房子，或者从乡村搬到城市。然后你身边的人开着稍微好一点的车，穿着稍微好一点的衣服，他们的指甲总是做好的，头发总是弄好的，他们去进行每月的面部护理和按摩。不知不觉中，你发现自己在做同样类型的事情。在我的客户中，我发现这较少关于——我的客户通常不是那种非常注重名牌的人，但我们都会
influenced by our peers. So it could be that they start trying to match the lifestyle of people around them, spending more money on hiking here, let's say, or camping here or whatever it is. And so when you find yourself in a place where you're spending more than maybe you anticipated or that you want to be, I always invite people to come back to how much is this purchase in alignment with my values? Because research shows that when we spend in alignment with our values, we are much more likely to rank that purchase as making us happy. So for example, I personally am not a camping fan. I grew up camping, but I don't like doing it now. So if my friends were to say, let's go camping and I had to buy, you know, a new sleeping bag and a new lantern and all this stuff, I would probably be pretty cranky about that purchase because
受到同龄人的影响。所以可能是他们开始试图迎合周围人的生活方式，比如说在这里花更多的钱去远足，或者在这里露营，或者无论是什么。因此，当你发现自己花的钱比你预期的或你想要的要多时，我总是邀请人们回到这个问题：这项购买与我的价值观有多大程度的一致性？因为研究表明，当我们按照自己的价值观进行消费时，我们更有可能将这种消费评价为让我们感到快乐。例如，我个人不是一个露营迷。我是在露营中长大的，但我现在不喜欢这样。所以如果我的朋友说，我们去露营吧，而我不得不买，你知道，一个新的睡袋、一盏新灯笼和所有这些东西，我可能会对这笔购买感到很不爽，因为
it's not an alignment with my values. Now, however, if they were like, we're going camping, but you can just come along for the day and go hiking with us, I might be thrilled to buy a new pair of hiking boots and get to sleep at an Airbnb or at a hotel. Yeah. So that would be more in alignment with what matters to me is I still get to spend quality time with my friends. I purchase a pair of boots that I will be able to use on this, you know, excursion and other ones. And I'm not doing something that I don't love. So I encourage people to do a loving audit of what they're spending on. If they're spending a lot on on beauty or clothing or cars, ask yourself, how important are these things to me? For some people, they get so much
这与我的价值观不符。然而，如果他们说，我们要去露营，但你完全可以一起来度过一天，跟我们一起远足，我可能会很高兴去买一双新的远足靴，然后住在Airbnb或酒店里。是的。所以这会更符合对我很重要的是，我依然能和朋友共度美好时光，我买了一双我可以用在这趟远足和其他远足中的靴子，而且我没有做我不喜欢的事情。所以我鼓励人们对自己花钱的地方进行一次充满爱意的审计。如果他们在美容、服装或汽车上花了很多钱，问问自己，这些东西对我有多重要？对某些人来说，他们从
joy out of the creativity of trying new makeup trends and trying new hairstyles. Great. Go for it so long as you can afford it. But maybe for that person, they don't really care about going out to eat. It's not their thing. They're not a foodie. So maybe then they can dial back their spending in that area. So it's less about cutting everything and more about cutting the things that don't really matter to you. You have really shine a lot on my own financial decisions. I'm like, I'm so happy to do it. Yeah. And I think we have a word for this in Australia, very similar to lifestyle inflation called lifestyle creep. And I was having a discussion with my friend about this the other day.
尝试新美妆潮流和新发型的创造力中获得极大的快乐。太棒了。只要你负担得起，那就去做吧。但也许对那个人来说，他们并不真的在乎出去吃饭。这不是他们的菜。他们不是美食家。所以也许他们可以减少那方面的开支。因此，与其说是一刀切地削减一切，不如说是不去花那些对你并不真正重要的事情的钱。你确实对我的个人财务决定有了很多启发。我想，我太乐意这样做了。是的。我想我们在澳大利亚对这个词有一个说法，非常类似于生活方式膨胀，叫做生活方式蠕变。我前几天还在和我的朋友讨论这件事。
And I didn't think about it much. And then your explanation, I've been like, oh, like, dang, that is spot on. And as someone who is in their early 20s, you know, I've just started making serious money. As of a lot of my friends, it is so much, and I have money available to me. So it's so much easier to be like, oh, if I had had had. this money when I was younger, I would have spent it on this or that. And buying things that make me very instantly happy, but perhaps don't align to my values, as you said. Or what was the term you used? Was it alignment to your values? Yeah, alignment to your values. Yeah. And alignment to
而且我没怎么想过。然后听了你的解释，我一直在想，哦，天哪，真是太贴切了。作为一个20岁出头的人，你知道，我才刚开始赚到可观的钱。正如我的许多朋友一样，这实在太多了，我手头也有钱。所以很容易就会想，哦，如果我年轻时就有这些钱，我就会把它花在这个或那个上。买那些让我瞬间感到快乐的东西，但正如你所说，可能并不符合我的价值观。或者你用的是什么词？是符合你的价值观吗？是的，符合你的价值观。是的，还有符合
how much I'm probably going to use it. Like, I bought, yeah, I'm not even going to shame myself anymore because I feel like you would probably tell me off for it. But I would do it. But gently. Yeah, of course. You're good at your job. Exactly. But I'm sure there are many people listening who are like, oh, like that explains me to a tea. Lifestyle creep is so easy to get into.
我可能要使用它的频率。比如，我买了，是的，我甚至不再为自己感到羞耻了，因为我觉得你可能会为此责备我。但我会这么做的。但会温和地。是的，当然。你很擅长你的工作。没错。但我确信有很多在听节目的朋友会觉得，哦，这简直是在说我。生活方式蠕变太容易陷入了。
And especially when we think about social and group psychology and wanting to feel like we belong. And a great way to do that is to present the same kind of indicators or facade or material items as other individuals within the group that we want. approval from. So I think it's definitely something to think about. Now I want to pick your brain on relationships, particularly romantic relationships. So anecdotally, a lot of my friends have found incredible life partners, people that they love and are great people. And I think that's something that happens a lot in our 20s. And in Australia, there is a tendency to move in, or perhaps this is also in America, but to move in before you're engaged, before you're married, and sometimes to move in together but have split finances.
尤其是当我们想到社会和群体心理以及想要归属感时。而做到这一点的一个好方法就是展现出与我们希望得到其认可的群体中其他人相同的指标、外表或物质物品。所以我认为这绝对是值得深思的事情。现在我想听听你对人际关系的看法，尤其是浪漫关系。非正式地说，我的许多朋友都找到了令人难以置信的生活伴侣，他们是他们所爱的人，也是很棒的人。我认为这是我们在20多岁时经常发生的事情。在澳大利亚，有一种同居的倾向，或者也许这在美国也是如此，就是在订婚前、结婚前同居，有时甚至同居但财务独立。
So I feel like for those who are perhaps ready to make this decision or already have made this decision and are now trying to find their footing, can you talk us through some of the problems or issues they might face some of the things to account for? Of course. So that's what I did. I cohabitated with my partner for seven years. we actually bought a home together before we were engaged. And globally, that is becoming more common for partners to move in together,
所以我觉得对于那些可能准备好做出这个决定，或者已经做出这个决定现在正试图站稳脚跟的人来说，你能跟我们谈谈他们可能面临的一些问题或困惑，以及需要考虑的一些事情吗？当然。这就是我所做的。我和我的伴侣同居了七年。我们实际上在我们订婚前就一起买了一套房子。在全球范围内，伴侣同居变得越来越普遍，
share expenses or do a theirs, mine, and hours before getting married. We could go off on that for a whole other thing. But I would say, first of all, like, good for the two of you for acknowledging what works for you. And a great time to talk about money is, of course, in my opinion, anytime, but also when you're going through a life change. So as you're getting ready to move in together, if you're deciding you want to get engaged, if you already live together but you're looking to move, those are perfect times to bring up the money conversation. And what we know is that couples who talk about money report being happier
在结婚前分摊费用或建立各自、我的和我们的账户系统。我们可以就这个话题展开另一场长篇大论。但我想说的是，首先，祝贺你们俩认可了适合你们的方式。谈论金钱的绝佳时机，当然，依我之见，随时都可以，但也是当你经历人生转折的时候。因此，当你准备同居时，如果你决定想要订婚，如果你已经同居但正准备搬家，这些都是提出金钱话题的绝佳时机。我们所了解的是，谈论金钱的情侣报告的幸福感
than those that don't, which is different than the convert, which is couples who fight about money are more likely to report separation or divorce. So it is a myth that talking about about money will somehow break you apart. But we have to be conscious about how we are actually bringing it up. Because to your point, it's taboo. It's something we don't talk about. And particularly in both of our cultures, there's a lot of romanticism that floats around there about romantic relationships.
要高于不谈论金钱的情侣，这与相反的情况不同，也就是为金钱争吵的情侣更有可能报告分居或离婚。因此，谈论金钱会以某种方式导致你们分手的说法是一个迷思。但我们必须意识到我们实际上是如何提起这个话题的。因为正如你所说，这是个禁忌。这是我们不谈论的事情。特别是在我们两国的文化中，关于浪漫关系充斥着许多浪漫主义色彩。
Like, you know, we just love each other and everything else just takes care of itself. But, you know, love is a great part of a partnership and other things have to be in alignment as well. So again, kind of leading with the this is awkward, this is uncomfortable, and giving your partner heads up that you want to talk about money. So it could literally be, hey, babe, I know we're getting ready to think about moving apartments. I would love if we could sit down later this weekend and talk about what our budget is and then just see if we need. need to change anything about how we're splitting expenses. So what you're doing is you're coming to them at a neutral time. You're not coming at them when you're mad. You're not like, oh, my gosh,
就像，你知道，我们相爱，其他一切都会自然而然地解决。但是，你知道，爱是伴侣关系中伟大的一部分，其他事情也必须保持一致。所以同样地，以“这很尴尬，这很不舒服”开场，并提前给你的伴侣打个招呼，表明你想谈论金钱。所以可以直截了当地说，嘿，宝贝，我知道我们准备考虑换公寓了。如果这周末晚些时候我们能坐下来谈谈我们的预算，然后看看是否需要改变我们分摊费用的方式，我会很高兴的。所以你所做的是在你们关系处于中立的时候找他们。你不是在生气的时候去找他们。你不是那种，哦，天哪，
you blew our grocery money again. What's wrong with you? You're the worst, but you're not in that heated space. You're neutral. So you're coming at them from neutrality. You're also sharing how it's going to benefit the two of you. I want to make sure we can talk about our budget. I want to make sure we are on the same page about where we want to move. And then also, you're giving them a heads up so that they can prepare to have that conversation because so often we are caught totally off guard when somebody wants to have a hard conversation like that, or at least uncomfortable, maybe hard's the wrong word. But giving somebody a heads up can be helpful. And then to actually have that conversation, I recommend sitting down without distractions or as few distractions as
你又把我们的买菜钱花光了。你有什么毛病？你是最糟糕的，但你并不是处于那种情绪激动的状态中。你是中立的。所以你是带着中立的态度去找他们的。你还在分享这将如何对你们双方都有益。我想确保我们可以谈论我们的预算。我想确保我们在搬家地点上达成共识。然后，你还要提前通知他们，以便他们能够准备好进行那次对话，因为通常当有人想要进行这样一次艰难的对话时，我们完全会被打个措手不及，或者至少会感到不舒服，也许“艰难”这个词用错了。但提前给别人打个招呼会有所帮助。然后要真正进行那次对话，我建议在没有干扰或尽可能少干扰的情况下坐下来，
possible having one or two things per kind of conversation that you're going to talk about. So in this example, let's talk about our apartment budget and make sure we're still okay splitting expenses the way we have been. And then once you answer those two things, you kind of shut it down. Then you open the door to have a money conversation later on because what we want to do is build in what I call money dates. And that's where you're talking about money regularly, but it's not all the time. You can kind of table those money conversations for once a week or twice a month. And then you can also, when you're having that money discussion, also know your partner's boundaries and your boundaries, right? I know for me, if I suddenly get really quiet
每次谈话讨论一两件事情即可。所以在这种情况下，让我们谈谈我们的公寓预算，并确保我们仍然可以接受像以前那样分摊费用。一旦你回答了这两件事，你就可以结束话题了。然后你再为以后开启金钱对话敞开大门，因为我们想要做的是建立我所说的“金钱约会”。这就是你定期谈论金钱，但并不是无时无刻都在谈论。你可以把这些金钱对话安排在每周一次或每月两次。然后你也可以在进行金钱讨论时，了解你伴侣的界限和你的界限，对吧？我知道对我来说，如果我突然在讨论中变得非常安静，
in a discussion, that's a cue that I'm probably being like triggered a bit or I'm being pushed too far. And that's probably a time for me to say, you know what? I can feel my tension rising. Would it be okay if I stepped away for a few minutes and then came back. And then we also have to know when it's time to just shut down the conversation altogether and try later. So it could be, you know, I'm totally shut down. I take my five minute breather. I come back and I'm immediately emotionally disregulated again. That would be a cue for me to say, babe. Let's actually finish this conversation tomorrow. I'm kind of maxed out. I appreciate that we're talking about, but I can't, I can't keep going right now. So having some parameters around that conversation, acknowledging that it's awkward, not catching your partner
这就是一个信号，表明我可能有点被触发了，或者被逼得太过了。这可能是我说“你知道吗？我能感觉到我的紧张情绪在上升。如果我走开几分钟再回来，可以吗？”的时候。然后我们还必须知道什么时候该彻底结束谈话并稍后再试。所以可能是，你知道，我完全崩溃了，我进行了五分钟的呼吸调整。我回来了，但情绪马上又失控了。这将是一个信号，让我对宝贝说：“我们实际上明天再结束这个谈话吧。我有点达到极限了。我很感激我们一直在谈论它，但我现在不能、不能再继续下去了。”因此，围绕对话制定一些参数，承认这很尴尬，不要让你的伴侣
off guard are all tips that I would advise anyone, but particularly folks in their 20s. That is fabulous advice. I'm going to listen back to this. If I reach that stage where I'm thinking about money with my partner or someone else. So can I just pose one more anecdote to you? One more hypothetical. So say you and your partner really disagree about money or perhaps one of you is more generous with their income. I've definitely found myself in this position before where I was contributing to more items that we would both share or to trips or to petrol in the car, things like that.
感到措手不及，这些都是我会给任何人的建议，尤其是20多岁的年轻人。这真是绝妙的建议。如果我达到了与伴侣或其他人考虑金钱的阶段，我会回过头来听这个。所以我能再向你提出一个轶事吗？再假设一个情景。假设你和你的伴侣在金钱上有很大的分歧，或者你们中有一人对自己的收入更慷慨。我肯定发现自己以前处于这种位置，我为我们俩共享的更多项目、旅行或汽车汽油之类的事情出资。
I think that's obviously a place of great attention and perhaps there's greater room for comfort. in that scenario. What kind of ways would you approach this situation? So for sure, I would have the conversation about who is in charge of or who is responsible for each of these different financial expenses. So for many couples who live together and aren't married or who have chosen to not merge everything, I love doing a theirs, mine, in ours bank account system. That's where one person has their own money, the other person has their own money,
我认为这显然是一个充满巨大紧张感的地方，也许有更大的舒适空间。在这种情况下。你会用什么样的方式来处理这种情况？当然，我会就谁负责这些不同的财务开支进行对话。对于许多同居但未婚或选择不合并所有财务的情侣来说，我喜欢采用“各自、我的和我们的”银行账户系统。也就是一个人有自己的钱，另一个人有自己的钱，
and they contribute to a shared account that is only for joint expenses. So rent, petrol, groceries, things like that. Then whatever is in each of their individual accounts, they can spend or save as they like. Now, when it comes to one-off things like holiday, I think that's when having another conversation can be helpful. Like, hey, we have so-and-so's wedding in a few months.
他们将钱存入一个仅用于共同开支的共享账户。比如房租、汽油、杂货等。然后，在他们各自账户里的钱，他们可以随心所欲地花或存。现在，说到像度假这样的一次性事情，我认为这时进行另一次对话会很有帮助。比如，嘿，我们在几个月后要参加某人的婚礼。
I think we should probably set aside some money for it. How are we going to do that? So having those conversations ahead of time can be hugely, hugely helpful. And then if you do end up doing that type of accounting system, let's say, if your partner spends their money, not your joint money, in a way that you want to roll your eyes at, you have to be comfortable enough to let it go. So if they want to go spend their money on, I don't know, tuning up their car or buying a bunch of sneakers, so long as your shared expenses are met, you have to be really comfortable saying that's their money that they're allowed to spend how they want. So, you know, you know yourself, you know your relationship well and see if that would work for you. But that's the method I like.
我想我们可能应该为此留出一笔钱。我们要怎么做？所以提前进行这些对话可能会非常有帮助。如果你最终确实采用了这种记账系统，比方说，如果你的伴侣把他们的钱（不是你们的共同资金）花在让你想要翻白眼的方式上，你必须足够自在地放手。因此，如果他们想把钱花在，我不知道，修理他们的汽车或买一堆运动鞋上，只要你们的共同开支得到了满足，你必须能够非常自在地说那是他们的钱，他们有权按照自己想要的方式花。所以，你知道你自己，你很了解你们的关系，看看这是否适合你。但这是我喜欢的方法。
And the asterisk I will add there is that for that shared account, depending on the regulations or depending on your comfort level, you might not. be comfortable enough to actually open a joint checking account together. So then what you would do is kind of tally up your expenses and have one person, let's say rent was $1,000. One person would pay rent and the other person would pay for groceries, utilities, and phones. And that adds up to $1,000. That's another way to do it to where you're contributing somewhat equally to the household expenses. Yeah, and I think with everything you've just said, it's about being comfortable enough to approach your partner with these discussions and having, I think, a sense of vulnerability and honesty with them. And I love the advice that you've given throughout this, throughout these
我在那里要补充的一个星号是，对于那个共享账户，根据规定或根据你的舒适程度，你可能不愿意一起开设一个共同支票账户。那么你要做的是算一下你们的开支，让一个人支付，比方说房租是1000美元。一个人付房租，另一个人付杂货、公用事业和电话费。加起来正好是1000美元。这是另一种做法，你可以相对平等地分担家庭开支。是的，我认为通过你刚才所说的一切，关键在于要足够自在地与伴侣进行这些讨论，并且我认为，与他们在一起时要有一种脆弱感和诚实感。我喜欢你在整个过程中给出的建议，在这些
kind of discussions has been, name the feeling. And be really honest about it. And I think when you're able to do that and you're able to be like, this is uncomfortable, you're, almost create kind of like an equal footing, an equal, a level playing field for you and the other person. Okay. I want to just ask you, any final pieces of advice. I also want to talk about your book, which I can see. You guys can't see it, but I can see is right over your shoulder. I think it's an amazing resource.
类型的讨论中，就是说出这种感觉。并且要对此非常诚实。我想当你能够做到这一点，并且能够说出“这很不舒服”时，你几乎创造了一种平等的立足点，为你和另一个人创造了一个公平的竞争环境。好的。我只想问你，有什么最后的建议吗？我还想谈谈你的书，我能看到。你们大家看不到，但我能看到它就在你的肩膀后面。我认为这是一个了不起的资源。
So I'll give you some space now to, if you've got any final thoughts, final piece of advice, and then please plug away because I want people to know your content and to know who you are. I think it's amazing. Thank you. Yes, one final thing that I add to almost all of my conversations is that no matter where you are in your journey with money, plan to make mistakes. Rather than planning on learning and executing things perfectly, know that you will make more money mistakes.
所以现在我把空间留给你，如果你有什么最后的想法、最后的建议，然后请宣传一下，因为我想让人们了解你的内容并知道你是谁。我认为这太棒了。谢谢你。是的，我几乎在所有对话中都会补充的最后一件事是，无论你处于财务旅程的哪个阶段，都要做好犯错的计划。与其计划把事情学好并完美执行，不如知道你会犯更多的金钱错误。
And that's perfectly fine, just as we expect to make mistakes in other. areas of our life. We're going to burn dinner. We're going to lose directions to a restaurant we're supposed to go to. You're going to make mistakes. This is a part of the journey. And rather than beating yourself up or being hard on yourself, I invite the listeners to just extend themselves some compassion that this stuff is hard and awkward and complicated. And it will take more than one podcast episode, as great as this one is, more than one podcast episode, more than one more than one YouTube video to start cultivating a healthy relationship with money. So give yourself lots of permission to make mistakes.
这完全没问题，就像我们预期在生活其他领域会犯错一样。我们会把晚餐烧糊。我们会迷失要去餐馆的路。你会犯错。这是旅程的一部分。与其自责或对自己严苛，我邀请听众对自己多一些同情，因为这些事情很难、很尴尬且很复杂。这需要不止一期播客节目（尽管这一期很棒），不止一期播客节目，不止一个YouTube视频，才能开始培养与金钱的健康关系。所以允许自己犯很多错误。
Know that that's totally normal. And I plan to make many more in my life. Yeah. Yeah. Very great advice. And then can you also give us an overview of first in a book, but also of your services, if people are interested. Because I feel like if you are someone who is listening to this episode, you probably are
知道这完全是正常的。我计划在我的生活中犯更多错误。是的。非常棒的建议。然后你还能不能给我们大致介绍一下你的书，以及如果人们感兴趣的话，你的服务。因为我觉得如果你是听这集节目的听众，你可能
struggling with financial anxiety. or how to navigate finances in relationships a little bit. So can you talk more about what you offer and how you go about it? Of course. So my business is called Mind Money Balance. You can find me in all the social places at that handle. My podcast is of the same name. My website's of the same name.
正在与财务焦虑作斗争，或者对如何在人际关系中处理财务感到困惑。所以你能多谈谈你提供什么以及你是如何做的吗？当然。我的企业叫做“Mind Money Balance”。你可以在所有社交平台上通过这个名字找到我。我的播客同名。我的网站也同名。
And I help people at the intersection of money and mental health. And I do that through coaching, therapy, and speaking engagements. So I invite you if you enjoyed this conversation to follow along and see if there's any other content that resonates. And then my book is called The Financial Anxiety Solution. It is a workbook. It's highly interactive. It is really focused on some of the things that we covered today. How do you think about money?
我通过金钱与心理健康的交汇点来帮助人们。我通过教练、治疗和演讲来实现这一点。因此，如果你喜欢这次对话，我邀请你关注并看看是否有其他引起共鸣的内容。我的书叫做《财务焦虑解决方案》。它是一本练习册。它具有高度的互动性。它确实专注于我们今天讨论的一些事情。你如何看待金钱？
How do you feel about money? What are your financial behaviors? How much are they helping you or harming you? And it gives you a lot of tools to help you dive. down that anxiety, normalize it, and help you learn to recognize your own patterns in terms of your relationship with money. And you can get that book. I invite you to have your independent bookseller order it for you, but of course you can get on Amazon. But I just like keeping money in the local bookstores as much as possible. Yeah. If you're in Australia, I also think
你对金钱有什么感觉？你的财务行为是什么？它们对你的帮助或伤害有多大？它为你提供了许多工具，帮助你深入了解、消除这种焦虑，将其正常化，并帮助你学会识别自己在与金钱关系方面的模式。你可以买到那本书。我邀请你让你的独立书商为你订购，当然你也可以在亚马逊上买到。但我只是尽可能地把钱留在本地书店里。是的。如果你在澳大利亚，我也认为
that that's something you should do, go to your local bookstore. They don't get enough support. Well, thank you so much. We have been speaking for almost an hour. It's just flown by. And I honestly think that I kind of got a personal therapy session out of this going to life. My pleasure. I truly love talking about this topic.
你应该这样做，去你当地的书店。他们得到的支持还不够。非常感谢。我们已经聊了快一个小时了。时间过得真快。老实说，我觉得我从这次生活中得到了个人治疗般的体验。我的荣幸。我真的很喜欢谈论这个话题。
No matter what stage of life you're in, that this topic is important. And I'm so honored that you said yes to having me on. And I hope all the listeners took little bits and pieces away from this. Yeah. I absolutely think that they did. This has been one of my favorite episodes. So a big thank you to Lindsay. Thank you so much.
无论你处于人生的哪个阶段，这个话题都很重要。我很荣幸你答应让我上节目。我希望所有的听众都从中收获了一点一滴。是的。我绝对认为他们做到了。这是我最喜欢的节目之一。非常感谢林赛。非常感谢。
Yeah. And if you do want to know more about this topic, please follow her. Her Instagram is incredible and provides just really amazing bite-sized pieces of advice that you can filter into your own lifestyle and as you see fit.
是的，如果你确实想了解更多关于这个话题的信息，请关注她。她的Instagram非常棒，提供了真正精彩、精炼的建议，你可以将这些建议融入你自己的生活方式，视情况而定。
As always, thank you so much for tuning into this episode, this special guest episode. I really loved having Lindsay on board. And as always, if you enjoyed the show, if you enjoyed the episode today, please give a five-star rating on Spotify podcast, Apple Podcasts, wherever you are listening right now, it really helps the podcast to grow and to reach more people. Additionally, if you're really enjoying the content, we now have a paid subscriber version where you get bonus content every month.
一如既往，非常感谢收听本期特别嘉宾节目。我真的很高兴请到林赛来做客。一如既往，如果你喜欢这个节目，如果你喜欢今天的节目，请在Spotify播客、苹果播客或你现在收听的任何地方给予五星好评，这真的对播客的成长和接触更多人有很大帮助。此外，如果你真的很喜欢这些内容，我们现在推出了付费订阅版本，你每个月可以获得独家内容。
If you're interested, please go to the link in the podcast description. And thank you again for listening. I'm sure I'll see you next week when we will be discussing more about the psychology of our 20s. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
如果你感兴趣，请点击播客简介中的链接。再次感谢你的收听。我相信我们下周见时将讨论更多关于20多岁心理学的内容。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，这对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。
Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all?
每一集，我们都会挑选一年，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。84年是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？
You're listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. how many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen and learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
你正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，而在其他任何地方进行这些对话其实都是不安全的，但你是在与一位深谙此道的持证专业人士进行对话。多少男人穿着铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听并学习《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，真人秀明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吧？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的脑洞大开了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证是真人制作本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。